bonjour à toutes et à tous bienvenue
dans ce nouveau numéro de skins hague
quels sont les enjeux de demain en
termes d'aménagement du territoire
nous verrons quels sont les moyens mis
en oeuvre pour réduire la distance
domicile travail et les multiples
logements en construction actuellement
sur tout le territoire
l'hyper centre de montigny le bretonneux
n'aura plus le même visage dans quelques
années nous évoquons ces changements à
venir
nous parlerons innovation avec le ski
high tech les navettes suspendu
l'aménagement c'est aussi les zones
commerciales très importantes sur le
territoire nous ferons le point sur les
constructions en cours et les zones
réhabiliter construction innovation et
environnement saint quentin en yvelines
a souhaité conserver sa ruralité et ses
espaces naturels
nous verrons comment les habitants
peuvent s'impliquer et participer
l'aménagement du territoire ont fait le
tour c'est parti
[Musique]
saint quentin en yvelines territoire
entre ville et campagne
l'agglomération s'est façonné au fil du
temps en tenant compte des différentes
caractéristiques qui composent ces
villes et en cherchant à s'adapter et à
innover pour répondre aux évolutions et
aux besoins des populations les enjeux
ils sont multiples ils sont des enjeux
d'aménagement en termes de création de
logements des enjeux d'aménagement pour
accueillir de nouvelles entreprises ou
préserver celle que nous avons sur notre
territoire
et puis tout en préservant je dirais des
caractéristiques de notre agglomération
qu'elles soient parfois agricole zones
urbaines plus ou moins denses donc c'est
d'arriver à marier tout ça avec un
réseau de transport ou en tout cas de
réseau routier aussi qui
arrive à s'adapter pour fil du temps le
plan local de déplacement a été maintes
fois remanié afin de répondre aux
besoins des entreprises des populations
mais aussi dans le but de favoriser le
rapprochement domicile travail sur les
145 mille emplois coffre l'agglomération
deux tiers sont occupés par des salariés
vivent en dehors du territoire
développement des pôles gares et des
transports en commun en site propre pour
limiter les embouteillages doublement du
pont guy schuller amour pas
enfouissement de la rn10 à trappes
l'agglomération s'attache aussi à créer
une offre de logement on voit bien qu'il
ya beaucoup de mouvement ce qu'on
appelle des mouvements poèmes
pendulaires aujourd'hui entre saint
quentin en yvelines et paris par exemple
qui fait que créer effectivement
beaucoup de bouchons de compte il faut
avoir une offre de logements qu'ils
soient adaptés à tous types de salariés
qui répondent vraiment à leurs besoins
ça va du logement social au pavillon
j'irai pour ceux qui souhaitent habiter
plus à la campagne
le clan logement de l'habitat signé par
les douze communes du territoire prévoit
la construction de 1700 logements par an
répartis sur les 12 villes et puis il ya
eu tout un travail qui a été fait aussi
avec action logement pour et avec les
tpe et pme pour justement identifier les
besoins de leurs salariés
ces dernières années quantité de projets
immobiliers ont vu le jour à trappes
le projet de la zone d'aménagement
concerté toujours en construction
comprendra à terme 950 logements du
logement social au logement en accession
à la propriété de l'appartement pour
jeunes ménages ou pour les familles ce
nouveau quartier entre les merisiers et
la plaine de nos offres
une autre image de la ville
[Musique]
à voisins le bretonneux la zac de la
remise devrait accueillir un écoquartier
500 logements ils sont prévues mais
aussi des commerces et des bureaux à la
verrière mille logements sont prévus à
villepreux 250 logements doit être
aménagé dans la zone de la centralité
c'est une zone qui est très importante
dans la ville c'est une zone très
particulière parce qu'elle permet de
relier le nord au sud est de faire
vraiment ce lien entre les quartiers de
la ville
toute la zone cette zone verte qui ne
représente que du vert mais sans aucune
vie nous allons leur pensée lui donnait
vraiment du sens lui donner des nouveaux
usages permettent aux familles de venir
ou
aux associations mettre de la vie met de
la nature tout ça pour vraiment quand on
arrive ici on se dit mais c'est ça de
l'épreuve situé en entrée de ville
l'endroit rebaptisé centre un parc
comptera 250 logements
l'ex rd98 désormais avenue de lieutenant
maurice hervé sera déviée les abords de
central park sur mon ainsi sécurisé
notamment pour les collégiens le projet
est né d'une vaste concertation auprès
des habitants durant toute une année
autre aménagement à villepreux la
pépinière
ce bois actuellement en friche deviendra
fin février 2020 un parc forestier
les travaux commenceront en octobre de
cette année et ça va être un réel parc
forestier pratiquement à l'intérieur de
la ville en lien avec le parc sportif
que nous avions fait au cours du premier
mandat et puis le fameux central park
qui va naître du projet que nous allons
construire au niveau de cette centralité
autre aménagement celui de l'hyper
centre situé sur la commune de montigny
le bretonneux l'endroit secteur
emblématique du territoire englobe la
gare de saint quentin en yvelines les
abords de l'université et du canal
urbain construit dans les années 80 il
s'agit aujourd'hui de réinventer cet
espace la gare de saint quentin en
yvelines le canal urbain les abords de
l'université sky one ce jusqu'à l'avenue
nicolas agout l'hyper centre de
l'agglomération devrait ces prochaines
années
offrir un visage neuf on connaît un
certain nombre d'immeubles d'entreprises
et dont on voit bien que ils
vieillissent c'est le cas par exemple de
l'immeuble de la poste avenue du centre
c'est le cas de l'anneau rouge à
l'entrée de la gare et donc il ya un
très gros travail qui est fait avec ça
sur le domaine de l'immobilier
d'entreprise pour reconstruire de
nouveau de nouveaux bâtiments beaucoup
plus moderne beaucoup plus attractif et
puis un très gros travail qui va être
lancée également sur la restructuration
de tout ce centre le canal urbain le
quai trou faut avoir une place de gars
vraiment qu'ils digne de ce nom les
inimités seront associés à la démarche
puisque une concertation sera mise en
place afin que chacun puisse donner son
avis
les entreprises sont le fleuron du
territoire l'agglomération se concentre
désormais sur le pôle ski high-tech où
vont se déployer les entreprises les
plus innovantes
l'innovation c'est aussi les transports
avec les navettes suspendu à
saint-quentin-en-yvelines l'innovation
passe par les entreprises automobile
aérospatiale numérique donc et finance
énergie
dix sept mille entreprises se sont
implantées dans l'agglomération une
présence qui permet de comptabiliser 145
mille emplois on a de très bons
résultats en développement économique et
en plus ça s'améliore on l'a vu
notre gros salon international que l'on
a au mipim
on voit bien mis entre juges sur les
engagements des entreprises sur leurs
souhaits sur le fait qu'ils veulent
prendre des locaux où s agrandit et puis
on a aussi un autre pôle qui est le pôle
high tech qui est sûr et l'encours
trappe plaisir qui lui accueille de
grandes entreprises comme airbus ou
zodiac et auquel on voudrait donner une
identité plus marquée en termes
d'innovation donc il y est prévu
l'ajustement mais on a mis en place des
outils pour y développer de nouvelles
entreprises qui soit dans l'innovation
et dans le même type de développement
saint quentin qui a la chance devant des
très belles d'entreprise donc nous on
doit suivre et on suit et notamment par
le biais des transports les plus
innovants avec l'idée de relier
peut-être ce pôle à la gare de
saint-quentin par un mode de transport
qui sera un mode de déplacement dans les
airs à la demande c'est ça qui est très
nouveau
un projet conçu par la start-up supra
ways les navettes autonome sup raskaï
fonctionneront à l'énergie solaire
celles ci seront disponibles à la
demande du passager depuis son
smartphone 24 heures sur 24 et 7 jours
sur 7
[Musique]
les zones commerciales font partie
intégrante du paysage saint quentinois
premier pôle commercial des yvelines de
nouvelles constructions sont
actuellement en cours
d'autres zones vont être réhabilités
[Musique]
l'agglomération saint-quentinoise est
riche de ces zones commerciales plus de
2 milliards d'euros de chiffre
d'affaires et 20 mille emplois ces zones
se dessine en trois axes majeurs plaisir
des claies maurepas coignières et
montigny le bretonneux actuellement
différents chantiers sont en cours
l'open sky à plaisir avec 30 nouveaux
commerces livrée au printemps 2020 aux
clayes-sous-bois le réaménagement de la
gare permettra une jonction avec
l'hypermarché auchan à montigny le
bretonneux
le nouveau projet au sein de skywest
devrait aboutir pour la fin de l'année
2019 là d'une nouvelle activité
virtuelle et autour du sport et du
loisir seront proposés aux saint
quentinois
nous avons une stratégie claire c'est de
dynamiser de travailler sur les zones
existantes
c'est à dire que la stratégie de
l'agglomération n'est pas de créer de
nouvelles zones commerciales parce que
je rappelle qu'on a le double de surface
commerciale par rapport à la moyenne
française
on a dix centres commerciaux sur plus de
300 mille mètres carrés ce qui est déjà
énorme et l'évolution en termes de
d'habitants dont habitants
ne va pas suffire j'allais dire à
permettre à d'autres zones commerciales
de se développer
donc aujourd'hui on est raisonnable les
zones commerciales existantes seront
requalifiés paris ouest le forum du
gibet et les portes de chevreuse dans un
appel à projets de l'état là encore
complétée par la construction de
logements le but sera aussi de dégager
une cohérence entre maurepas et
coignières à montigny le bretonneux
l'espace saint quentin devrait aussi
évoluer autour du projet de l'hyper
centre
le territoire travaille aussi à répondre
aux attentes des habitants qui réclament
de plus en plus de développement de
circuits courts et des produits made in
france
malgré toutes ces constructions le plan
local d'urbanisme intercommunal prévoit
le respect des espaces protégés comme
les milieux naturels ou les zones
agricoles des espaces cher aux saint
quentinois
c'est primordial pour moi
pour moi c'est essentiel d'avoir de
l'espace vert est un endroit où on peut
se balader à respirer pas parce que
j'aime la nature tout simplement quand
j'ai besoin de nature pour lui c'est
tout un oui c'est magique fois
j'habiterai nulle part ailleurs j'habite
juste derrière et en fait c'est de
mauvais lauch peut aller jusqu'à la
minière son troisième voiture et je
pourrai pas habiter dans une ville où je
vois des voitures tout le temps on a la
chance quand même d'avoir un beau parc
et la minière qu'un peu plus loin
donc voilà pour les garder quoi c'est
vraiment important
si j'habite là c'est en partie à cause
de ça
saint quentin en yvelines possède 60%
des espaces naturels des espaces
aquatiques boisés ou encore des chants
et des étendues d'herbe 5000 hectares de
surfaces végétalisée 38 bassin de
stockage 78 mille arbres
aujourd'hui plus de la moitié du
territoire saint quentinois est composé
des espaces verts autant d'éléments
naturels qui lutte contre le changement
climatique et offre une autre vision de
l'agglomération
c'est justement ce qui fait partie du
charme de saint quentin en yvelines
c'est que c'est quand même une
agglomération qui est réussie parce que
il ya beaucoup de verdure quand vous
vous promenez il ya des belles allées
arborées et donc du coup avec le service
aménagement nous travaillons sur un plan
paysage ce plan paysage avec le concours
des habitants de l'agglomération
déterminera les vues à préserver ou
celles à rénover espaces naturels comme
l'espace urbain
côté centre ancien et hameaux le service
de l'aménagement prévoit de donner les
outils aux communes afin de protéger les
éléments remarquables ce qui marque
c'est fini travel été à toutes et à tous
ce job
[Musique]